Just a few weeks shy of her
100th birthday, the iconic,
beloved, and groundbreaking Betty White
passed away, on December 31st, 2021.
A few days before, on December 28th,
the actor took to Instagram to share
her latest cover of People magazine with
fans, the headline of which read "Betty
White turns 100!" with a quotation
reading "Funny never gets old."
The magazine includes an exclusive
interview with the actress,
which was one of White's last before her
passing, while also featuring several
of White's friends — including actors Ryan
Reynolds, Carol Burnett, and Sandra Bullock.
On top of that, the cover references the
legendary actor's "secrets for happiness."
Having lived for such a long time, White
witnessed plenty of change in the world,
including the rise of social media, and she
adapted to everything with grace. Her Instagram
account has 1.9 million followers who eagerly
awaited any and all news White posted about.
White's prolific portfolio of award-winning work,
her efforts as an animal rights activist, and the
lasting impact she had in the world of comedy
will no doubt be celebrated for years to come,
but her final Instagram post is causing its fair
share of heartbreak for her fans around the world.
White captioned her last Instagram post,
"My 100th birthday… I cannot believe it is coming
up, and People Magazine is celebrating with me!"
In a matter of hours, the Dec. 28th post garnered
a large amount of likes and comments, and as one
fan wrote in the wake of the news of her death,
"she is forever a golden girl in our hearts."
The ultimately heartbreaking post currently
sits at well over 600k likes and counting,
with a heartwarming comment from one
follower reading simply, "National treasure."
White's career spans nearly eight decades, and
in that time, the five-time Emmy Award-winning
Illinois native also took on the
roles of writer and producer.
As an actor, she brought an endless list
of unforgettable characters to life.
While her character on "Golden Girls"
is arguably her most well-known,
she also made her mark with performances
in other projects like "Hot in Cleveland,"
"The Proposal," and "The Mary Tyler Moore Show."
In the People magazine feature, friend and
costar Sandra Bullock (who starred in "The
Proposal" with White) said she hoped White would
celebrate her birthday the same way she, quote,
"celebrated every day of her life with
humor, kindness and a vodka on ice,
toasting to the fact that she's a
badass who has left us all in the dust."
While the occasion is now much sadder than it
should have been, many people around the world
are still planning to celebrate the life of
Betty White on what would have been her 100th
birthday on January 17th, 2022. The plans
already in place include a documentary movie
special that will be in theaters for one night
only, called "Betty White: 100 Years Young."
A short trailer for the movie,
distributed by Fathom Events,
includes clips from the entertainer's long career,
as well as an invitation from White herself,
telling fans that "there is only one place to
get the real Betty White," and that's here in
this movie. What better way to celebrate the
life of Betty White than to spend January
17th celebrating with the woman herself?
The producers of the movie, Steve
Boettcher and Mike Trinklein,
shared their thoughts about the prolific actress
in a statement after her death. They said,
"Betty always said she was the 'luckiest
broad on two feet' to have had a career as
long as she did. And honestly, we were the
lucky ones to have had her for so long."
Clarifying their plans for the film, they stated
that the movie will still premiere as planned,
to, quote, "provide a way for all who loved her
to celebrate her life — and experience
what made her such a national treasure."
The movie will highlight White's fantastic,
long career, including her final interview,
and showcase the many friends who loved her so
much, including Ryan Reynolds, Carol Burnett,
Robert Redford, Clint Eastwood,
Valerie Bertinelli, and many more.